hola buenas noches y gracias por el
espacio en realidad de este proyecto de
reforma de ley incluye cosas o digamos
que regular cosas que ya están
sucediendo y que sencillamente les da
una cabida a nivel legislativo es decir
por ejemplo asociaciones de salud que
tienen que ver con endometriosis o
problemas menstruales sus usuarias o
personas que tienen esta situación ya
están recurriendo a bajas médicas lo que
pasa que no tiene una cabida específica
y al no estar reguladas pues por ejemplo
son son bajas que no se cobran no
entonces lo que la ley intenta es dar
cabida y regularizar esta situación yo
entiendo o espero que sí que se pueda
mantener porque está previsto para
incapacidades temporales de reglas no de
cualquier regla sino de reglas dolorosas
e incapacitantes ahora la maternidad es
ampliamente abordada desde las
posibilidades del aborto pasando por los
permisos de maternidad e incluso
rechazando fuertemente la gestación
subrogada qué opina del texto en estos
apartes
en realidad por ejemplo en relación al
aborto lo que implica es volver a la
situación anterior a la reforma que
realizó el pp de acuerdo entonces
básicamente elimina los tres días de
pensárselo en relación al aborto la
obligación de información previa es
decir existe la opción es opcional pero
no es obligatoria e incluye que puedas
tener un permiso para recuperarte
después de una interrupción del embarazo
ya sea voluntaria o fortuita
asegura que puedas tener como las dos
opciones farmacológicas o quirúrgicas en
los centros en relación a la edad ya
acceder al aborto efectivamente vuelve a
la situación anterior a la última
reforma porque porque esto está pensado
sobre todo para mujeres chicas en
situación de especial vulnerabilidad que
pueden tener represalias en su entorno
en caso de que se conozca la situación
de embarazo y en relación al permiso
desde la semana 39 pre parto me parece
interesante especialmente en un contexto
en que en españa sobre todo las mutuas
han endurecido los requisitos para
acceder a bajas o permisos justo antes
de dar con lo cual muchas mujeres tienen
que acudir a bajas pues por dolor de
espalda y otro tipo de circunstancias y
de nuevo esta ley intenta dar cabida a
esto
marta busquets gallego abogada experta
en derecho generalizados muchas gracias
por acompañarnos para analizar este tema
aquí en france 24